et bellamy à tête de liste les
républicains aux élections européennes
qui est à sur ce plateau merci d'être là
ce matin
évidemment toujours seulement sur ce
plateau
évidemment vous êtes là est d'abord on
va commencer par cette conférence de
presse des manuels macron hier soir
votre sentiment
comment avez vous trouvé le président
sur le fond mais aussi sur la forme mais
ce qu'il a répondu aux attentes des
français sont le premier sentiment qui
me vient en regardant cette conférence
de presser au fond tout ça pour ça il
aura fallu des semaines de ce grand
débat soigneusement mis en scène il aura
fallu surtout des des semaines d'une
crise sociale qui a profondément
fracturé la société française qui a
constitué l'occasion d'un désordre
rituel qui a pesé lourdement sur notre
économie sur notre vie collective pour
qu'on en arrive enfin à la re découverte
de ces évidences que pour notre part
nous disons depuis longtemps mais qu'il
aurait suffi d'un peu des coudes pour
pouvoir entendre plus tôt le président
de la république comme le premier
ministre il ya quelques jours aura mis
des semaines pour découvrir que oui il y
a un problème de fiscalité en france et
que nous sommes le pays qui prélève le
plus de prélèvements obligatoires au
monde et que oui cela pèse
douloureusement sur les classes moyennes
sur les français il aura fallu des
semaines pour découvrir que
effectivement notre pays est dans une
situation de grande tension sociale et
et nous regrettons pour notre part je
regrette en tous les cas que tout ce
temps était perdue alors que si on avait
été un peu plus tôt à l'écouté de ceux
qui sur le terrain je pense aux élus
locaux je pense au maire tirait déjà la
sonnette d'alarmé depuis longtemps sans
doute on n'aurait pas eu besoin de tout
ce temps période en dehors du temps
perdu et ce qu'il a répondu à ce que les
français attendaient pour partie c'est
vrai que vous êtes en partie satisfait
par exemple la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est une bonne nouvelle j'aime
si les entreprises vont être mises à
contribution je ne peux pas ne pas me
satisfaire que certaines mesures soit
prises qui correspondent exactement à ce
que nous demandions je ne suis pas dans
une opposition systématique et aveugle
nous avons dit depuis des semaines il je
le pense profondément que nous avons
besoin effectivement de voir baisser
l'impôt sur le revenu qu'il faut ré
indexer tout les retraites sur
l'inflation parce que les retraites sont
là
l'ugta de toute une vie de travail et
qu'on ne peut pas jouer avec les
retraites pour ajuster les finances
publiques cela étant dit le vrai
problème le vrai sujet c'est que les
français ne sont pas dupes au fond si on
veut pouvoir faire baisser le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires si on veut
faire baisser la charge fiscale qui pèse
sur tant de nos concitoyens
il faut évidemment une baisse de la
dépense publique et il n'y aura pas de
vraie baisse de la fiscalité
s'il n'y a pas de vraie baisse de la
dépense publique sauf à faire peser
notre consommation d'aujourd'hui et nos
inconséquences du présent sur les
générations qui viennent ce qui me
paraît être la plus grande des
injustices mais et donc il dit sur ce
plan là sur ce plan-là pardonnez moi je
crois que nous avons eu droit à un vrai
renoncement le président de la
république a reculé sur la seule mesure
d'économie qu'il avait promis de prendre
il a reculé sur la baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires ce n'est pas un totem
bien sûr mais il faut que notre état
parviennent à faire mieux avec moins
sinon évidemment nous continuerons de
faire peser sur les générations qui
viennent notre incapacité à réformer la
dépense publique willy nous allons faire
des économies en amenant les français à
travailler plus parce qu'on va recréer
le plein emploi
et puis grâce à la productivité et
ensuite en supprimant des niches
fiscales sur les entreprises alors
supprimer les niches fiscales sur les
entreprises ça veut dire augmenter la
fiscalité en fait ça n'est rien d'autre
que cela les niches fiscales on se
demande d'abord où il va les trouver
parce que j'entendais sur votre plateau
plusieurs intervenants se demander ce
que signifiait exactement cette
suppression de niches fiscales
si ça se réalise en tous les cas ça ne
sera rien d'autre qu'une augmentation de
la pression fiscale
quant à la question de ce pacte
productif
cela fait partie pardonnez moi mais
c'est aussi quelque chose qui me frappe
en écoutant le président de la
république françois sureau qui est assez
proche de lui avait évoqué il ya
quelques semaines dans une intervention
médiatique
ce langage invraisemblable qui je crois
fait perdre beaucoup de son sens à la
vie publique il faut que les français
puissent comprendre leurs dirigeants
quand ils s'expriment et moi pour ma
part il ya beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels je n'ai tout simplement pas
compris ce que le président de la
république voulait non pardon on nous
parle effectivement d'un pacte productif
quand on nous parle d'une nouvelle étape
de la décentralisation mais très bien
pour faire quoi
dans quel cap quelle est la relation et
les options il l'a dit de ne plus de
responsabilités ou
aux élus locaux soit un certain nombre
de sujets enfin en tout cas il n'a pas
précisé lesquelles mais je veux dire
l'orientation c'est celle là mais tout
cela restait à dans une forme de flou
énorme quand il a dit d'ailleurs que les
élus locaux devaient assumer des
responsabilités démocratique en lien
avec les compétences qu'ils exercent je
crois que c'est quand même très étonnant
que le président de la république ne
voit pas et ne sache pas que cette
responsabilité démocratique elle est
pleine et entière aujourd'hui parce que
tous les élus locaux comme il l'a
rappelé lui même sont légitimées par
l'élection à laquelle ils s'astreignent
bien sûr donc je ne vois pas exactement
ce que tout cela peut bien vouloir dire
qu'est ce que c'est que ce patriotisme
inclusif qu'est ce que c'est que ce
conseil de défense écologique
nous avons des institutions pourquoi
inventer sans cesse de nouveaux comités
commissions de nouvelles structures de
nouveaux dispositifs
là où au contraire il faudrait avoir la
simplicité de fer avec les institutions
qui lui sont ouvertes pour pouvoir mener
son action
françois-xavier madame est ce que vous
n'avez pas eu le sentiment qui hier soir
et my own macro et est entré en campagne
et qui est allé chasser sur sur vos
terres nous l'évoquions effectivement il
a parlé de la famille
il a parlé d'immigration est ce que
finalement les sondages et le dernier
sondage du figaro vous crédité de 14%
d'intentions de vote
il ya effectivement une remontée dans
les sondages de nerfs vous n'êtes pas ce
sentiment là ce que vous n'avez pas
entendu le message qui nous est adressé
hier soir j'ai toujours considéré pour
ma part que la politique se dissolvait
dans le marketing et que l'on pouvait
pas précisément que d'engager les
français dans une vision si on était en
permanence en train de gérer les choses
en fonction de l'évolution des sondages
je ne sais pas si le président de la
république est dans une stratégie pour
aller capter tel ou tel électorat
ce qui est vrai c'est que sur beaucoup
de sujets j'ai la surprise de l'entendre
dire aujourd'hui des choses qui sont
bien éloignés de ceux qui le disaient
hier et qui ressemble plutôt à ce que
pour ma part pour notre part nous
tentions de défendre depuis longtemps je
pense notamment à la question de
l'immigration sur laquelle il emploie
des mots qui sont aujourd'hui très
proche de ce que j'ai pu employer par
exemple dans demeure un livre que j'ai
publié il ya quelques semaines lorsqu'il
parle de la nécessité de cette maison
qui doit avoir des murs pour pouvoir
accueillir ceux qui ont besoin de notre
solidarité
je ne retrouve pas le emmanuel macron
qui il ya quelques semaines encore nous
expliquer qu'il y avait d'un côté les
avocats des murs et de l'autre ceux qui
étaient applaudis de l'ouverture sur
l'immigration quel est votre différence
avec lui parce qu'il ya une chose qu'on
n'a pas bien comprise
est ce que vous vous demandez la
fermeture des frontières nationales à
l'intérieur de la zone schengen ou pas
nous demandons et c'est là une
différence majeure avec emmanuel macron
il l'a rappelé encore hier soir parce
qu'au delà des mots il ya les actions
nous demandons-nous que chaque état
puisse gérer sa politique migratoire en
europe nous voulons travailler ensemble
pour défendre les frontières extérieures
de l'europe
c'est le principe de ce que nous avons
appelé à double frontières il nous faut
une stratégie européenne concertée parce
que on ne peut pas imaginer que les pays
soient plus fort s'ils sont isolés face
aux défis migratoires mais il faut
simultanément que chaque état puisse
maîtriser sa propre politique migratoire
et emmanuel malaise que ça passe par la
fermeture de frontières avec l'italie
avec l'allemagne avec la belgique le
luxembourg
ça passe par le fait de permettre aux
états de mener des contrôles ciblés à
leurs frontières comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une
dérogation au code frontière de schengen
qui précise que cet exercice de contrôle
est possible dans le cadre de la menace
terroriste nous nous voulons pouvoir
maintenir cette dérogation en la fondant
sur le motif migratoires qui lui n'est
pas temporaire malheureusement parce que
la crise migratoire est devant nous si
nous ne savons pas faire face et donc
oui c'est vrai il faut que chaque état
puisse décider de sa politique
migratoire or hier emmanuel macron a été
très clair il a dit qu'il voulait sortir
de l'espace schengen des états qui ne
ferait pas preuve de solidarité et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la solidarité
ça veut dire la répartie sera de
l'immigrant absolument à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne là vous êtes content
nous nous croyons que l'union européenne
s'est perdue parce qu'elle a pensé
répartition au lieu de penser protection
et nous ne croyons pas que l'union
européenne pourra durer si elle impose
aux états qui la composent des quotas de
migrants cette politique ne fonctionne
pas elle est inhumaine à l'égard des
migrants eux mêmes
elle ne fonctionne pas non plus bien sûr
parce qu'elles donnent les sentiments
terrible et qui vont sont dépossédés
contrôler leur dû mais qu'est ce que
vous faites des travailleurs des
salariés qui chaque matin
traversent la frontière pour aller en
allemagne production mais vide
évidemment nous ne voulons pas revenir
sur la liberté de circulation au sein de
l'union européenne les comptes les
contrôles ciblés encore une fois ils
sont pratiqués depuis des mois
maintenant des dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont été refoulés à la
frontière franco italienne
ça n'empêche pas du tout les
travailleurs transfrontaliers de passer
tous les jours à la frontière franco
italienne à la frontière franco suisse à
la frontière franco allemande
il ya aucune espèce de difficulté avec
ça simplement ce que nous disons c'est
très important c'est qu'il faut que
chaque état garde le total contrôle de
sa politique migratoire en fonction de
ses capacités d'accueil et d'intégration
je vous allez adhérer au ppe ce qui
rassemblait les partis de droite au
niveau européen le candidat du ppe pour
la commission européenne ce monsieur
weber un allemand emmanuel macron ce
moteur est que le président la
commission européenne soit michel
barnier vous êtes pour l'allemand pour
le français je crois qu'on n'en est pas
encore à ce niveau de la discussion nous
venons devant les français avec d'abord
un projet clair où ils sont quinze
propositions quand même je me permets de
vous répondre 75 propositions pour
l'avenir de l'europe
nous venons devant les français aussi
avec une vraie clarté sur nos alliés
nous sommes membre du ppe cette grande
famille politique européenne au sein de
laquelle nous pouvons espérer faire en
sorte que l'europe se réoriente en
profondeur et ce que nous croyons
profondément c'est qu'il faut maintenant
qu un cap clair soit donnée la question
des personnes qui viendront mettre en
oeuvre ce cap ne se pose pas encore
hilmar et 120,30 ajouté il nous reste 31
jours avant l'élection transige allemand
souhaite d'abord monsieur waeber de la
commission selon les allemands pardonnez
moi c'est le ppe qui a élu son candidat
pour la présidence de la commission
européenne comme vous savez c'est une
procédure qui permet de relier le
résultat de l'élection européenne à la
présidence de la commission européenne
cela étant dit c'est une procédure qui
commence avant l'élection
ce qui compte c'est que les états
détermineront leur candidat pour la tête
de la commission et le parlement se
prononcera ensuite sur sa légitimité et
le ppe est dominée par la cdu allemande
la patronne de la cdu la nouvelle
patronne a cédé 10 il faut supprimer le
parlement européen à strasbourg parce
que c'est cause de dépenses donc il faut
le rapatrier exclusivement à bruxelles
et il faut que la france cède son siège
de membre permanent au conseil de
sécurité
à
l'union européenne qu'est ce que comment
vous allez faire au sein du ppe ou bien
nous disons nous sommes en désaccord
très radicales sur ces deux éléments que
vous venez d'évoquer et ce qui est très
important ce qu'il faut que les français
comprennent c'est que le processus de la
construction européenne c'est un
dialogue mais c'est un dialogue exigeant
entre les partenaires qui partagent
parfois des visions divergentes
je regrette moi pour ma part que cette
réponse de madame crâne car npower soit
le symptôme de l'affaiblissement de la
voix de la france en europe parce que
jamais sans doute on aurait répondu cela
à un chef d'état précédent emmanuel
macron à discréditer la france il l'a
marginalisé en défendant d'avoir une
vision de l'europe que personne ne
partage en europe et surtout et la
conférence de presse d'hier soir ne va
rien arranger à cela en mettant notre
pays dans une situation de crise assez
profonde notamment du point de vue de
ses engagements européens
nous sommes pour la première fois dans
l'histoire le vin qui le 28e pays sur 28
en matière de déficits publics dire nous
sommes derrière les italiens derrière
les grecs que pourtant hier nous
considérions comme les hommes malade de
l'europe il faut que nous puissions
retrouver notre crédibilité si nous
voulons être audible et il faudra être
audible pour défendre face aux allemands
les intérêts de la france le siège de
strasbourg le conseil de la france au
conseil de sé le siège de la france au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
tous tout cela est très important
françois-xavier bellamy dresse une
minute et je voudrais vous poser une
question revenir sur un truc semaine on
va parler de la reconstruction de notre
dame de paris vous avez appelé emmanuel
macron je cite on va le voir un peu
d'humilité pour cette reconstruction est
ce que vous pensez qu'il va trop loin
avec son projet de loi qui va permettre
de déroger à cette règle en matière de
reconstruction
pour obtenir les délais de new delhi de
cinq ans sur lesquels il s'est engagé ce
projet de l'offensé c'est un symptôme
est un problème c'est un symptôme
d'abord d'une espèce d'accélération du
temps de passion de l'immédiateté qui
fait que la cathédrale notre dame de
paris et est encore brûlante lorsqu'on a
commencé d'écrire un projet de loi qui
devait passer en urgence je crois qu'on
a besoin de prendre le temps devant
cette oeuvre hérités des siècles passés
on peut quand même se donner le temps de
réfléchir à la meilleure manière de
reconstruire la deuxième chose la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il est très
grave que le président de la république
court-circuit tous ceux qui dans notre
pays ont l'expertisé nécessaire pour
penser le travail de restauration
déroger à toutes les règles en vigueur
les règles de protection du patrimoine
les règles d'architecturé préventive les
règles des marchés publics pour pouvoir
aller plus vite peut être en vue des
jeux olympiques mais nous sommes très
ingrat envers ceux qui ont construit
cette cathédrale et qui savait en la
construisant qu'il ne verrait pas le
résultat de leurs oeuvres qu'ils ont
construites pour durer des siècles
lorsque nous accélérons ainsi le temps
au mépris de toutes les règles de
protection nécessaire pourtant face à un
joyau comme celui ci merci beaucoup
françois-xavier benyamine est revenu ce
matin sur le plateau de la matinale